[Music]
hey guys if you have watched the trailer
of jurassic world dominion then you
would have been shocked but a little bit
shocked at the size of one big aquatic
dinosaur oh wait it's not a dinosaur
it's a marine reptile it was seen in the
middle of the trailer when there was a
backdrop narration of dinosaurs being an
ecological disaster and cannot co-exist
with humans so in this clip we see a
huge ass mosasaurus probably the same
one from jurassic world the first movie
and a fallen kingdom
so here in this video we will estimate
the size of this beast and let me just
say this that it will have grown to be
the size of a kaiju
so subscribe if you haven't already and
now let's get down with it
the clone mosasaurus retained many
features of its original counterpart it
also had a bite force of 13 k 13 000
pounds per square inch 1 000 pounds per
square inch higher than the terrestrial
predator tyrannosaurus rex that lived in
the same period the master saw lived in
a 3 million gallon pool of water located
near main street known as jurassic world
lagoon while the official size of this
creature was said to be 56 feet long or
around 17.6 meters
of course we would disagree we could
disagree and using logic either the
creators didn't give a precise
measurement or wanted to stay true to
the scientific data of real-life fossils
okay in fallen kingdom the mossosaurus
was discovered to have survived for
months in the lagoon and was seen eating
the submersible along with the pilots of
that craft as well as a mercenary
hanging on a ladder of a helicopter
flying over the lagoon
here we actually see the true size of
the mososaurus in fallen kingdom being
bigger and at the end of the movie we
see it approaching surfers and it was
even bigger so psy's estimates for this
creature went from being 55 feet long
as seen in the innovation center of the
park to being over 80 feet long and even
more than 100 by some estimates
which i can agree on by looking at the
scene of it clamping down on the person
outside the helicopter
so next we come to the estimation of the
size of the mossosaurus as seen in the
jurassic world dominion trailer in one
of the clips of the trailer it was seen
tucking a crab catching boat and even
turning it sideways with its weight at
first we see it come out of the water
and grabbing a crab cage which is called
a crab trap with its huge mouth mind you
most crab traps are six to seven feet
long but this one is a little bit bigger
being around nine to ten feet as you can
see by comparing the number of steel
bars in the cage
so by looking at this we can say that
the head of the master service would be
at least 3 crab cages long the head
which means a snout and a skull which
means over 30 feet long
another clue to its size is the
adjoining scene where we can clearly see
a sailor falling into the sea when the
boat was turned sideways owing to the
tremendous weight of the sea monster
so by estimating the size of the sailor
and the width of the boat we can come to
another estimate on the size of the
mososaurus's mouth
let's say the sailor is on average
let's say a height of six feet tall we
can see that it takes around five of
these sailors to be equal to the width
of the boat and at the same time we can
see the snout of the mussosaurus and the
person's height being nearly equal to
its nose
so by doing some magic on the side we
can see that it takes around six of
these sailors to be equal to the head of
the mosasaurus
now let's do some math if one sailor is
six feet tall and it takes five of them
to be equal to the width of the boat
then the boat is 30 feet wide which
would make sense for a large crab
catching vessel like the alaskan king
crab fishing boats
then let's get to the mossosaur we can
see that it takes six of these sailors
to be equal to its head size
so its head alone is around 35 to 36
feet long
therefore as we can see by the image a
mososaurus head is roughly 20 of the
length of its entire body which means
the overall size of the mossosaurus of
dominion would come to be around 180
feet long as i said before the
mossosaurus is now the size of a kaiju
twice the size of a blue whale
so how much bigger can it get well we
will never know since this movie will be
the end of the franchise but we can
compare it with other sea monsters like
movie sea monsters
now let's see them
[Music]
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one
take care fam